like for me to to to isolate myself so
that i can hear god's voice there's an
easy way to do that tell yourself this
week i'm not turning the television on
i'm not turning the radio on i'm not
going to do email i'm not going to do
texting
then you've got time to spend the night
oh why i can't reach you sometime
the world is talking a lot about
mindfulness and meditation these days so
as long as we're meditating it's okay
right or is it
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness well welcome
everyone
to another episode of led live today we
have a couple of guests again we have
mike shreve and eric wilson joining us
today
very good to be here good to see you
yeah thank you guys for coming and
joining us to talk about meditation and
you guys have both
done some meditation in your past right
unfortunately yes yeah
very involved you're still doing some
meditation today
yes much much but it's a little
different right
maybe a lot different and that's what
we're going to talk about
so what what kind of meditation are we
going to start talking about
first um well it's it's funny because
we're going to be looking at hindu
meditation which mike is the
expert on that since he was a guru in
yoga for many many years
and then we're going to also look at the
buddhist and the taoist forms of
meditation
it was funny what you just said about
you know but you're still meditating
today and i thought about it i thought
i used to meditate you know three or
four or five hours a day when i was
in the martial arts and now
i meditate 20 hours a day i mean as long
as i'm awake i'm walking and i'm
thinking and talking to the lord
and thinking about his word so yeah
yeah there's definitely a huge
difference and
that was my entire life at one point
when i was a teacher of kundalini yoga
at four
universities back in 1970 and i was
running a yoga ashram
we would get up at 3 30 in the morning
and
i would be in some type of meditative
approach
until 5 30 that night whether it's
mantra yoga
or raji yoga or kundalini yoga or hatha
yoga
all of it is intertwined with meditative
techniques
and of course the bible also says pray
without ceasing and the only way to
achieve that
is to have a meditative mindset all day
long but there is a
huge difference between what i did
as a yoga teacher and what i believe now
as a christian as a follower of jesus
well let's talk about that i want to um
open today with a scripture verse that
really caught my attention a number of
years ago
this is found in deuteronomy chapter 32
verse 29 through 31.
and it's speaking to us all of us it's
like every person in the world
no matter what your beliefs are god
created you personally he loves each of
us
personally he doesn't view one of us as
as better than the other
but he's speaking to each of us through
his word personally
and this is what it says it says oh that
they were wise
and that they only understood this that
they would consider
their latter end for how should one
chase a thousand
or two put ten thousand to flight except
their rock had sold them and the lord
had shut them up
for their rock is not as our rock
even our enemies themselves know this
and then he goes on in the next verse
and he says something
that catches my attention it says for
their vine
is the vine of sodom and of the fields
of gomorrah
their grapes are grapes of gall or
poison
and bile and their clusters are bitter
their wine like it talks about in
revelation the wine of babylon
is the poison of dragons and the cruel
venom of asps
and when i read that and i thought about
mike
with with the chinese and the japanese
the dragon is seen as being the the the
figure that gives the most power
that's the most influential figure
in hinduism the serpent right is the
most
the kundalini power means serpent power
right
so you have here in this verse god is
warning us
about the venom of the dragon
and of the serpent and asp is a serpent
for those that might not be familiar
with the truth that's right
but you know in revelation chapter 12 it
says
speaking of satan it says the great
dragon
that old serpent called the devil and
satan
so in the in the scriptures the serpent
instead of being viewed as
as a mighty power that is you know
something to be
craved or sought after it's telling us
this is a symbol of satan the destroyer
i like how how it also describes like
even even
they know that this rock is not as big
as
you know this rock amen and i think
that's that's kind of neat i think
really uh you know god is god is your
sure
foundation he is your rock amen and the
biblical imagery is not one of the
serpent being
revered or lifted up i mean even from
the beginning in the garden
that's right you know when god cursed
the serpent it was like no you get to
crawl on the ground and eat dust all the
days of your life it's about as low as
you can go
yeah but it's the nature of the servant
or the serpent to elevate itself
you know that's a good point and the
whole purpose of meditation
when i was involved in yoga instantly
the word yoga means
yoke and its implication is union with
god
the whole purpose was to achieve god
consciousness
through these meditative practices and
for instance
uh we would spend much of the day
in mantra yoga which is a kind of
meditation that we may touch on later
but it was very important to have the
correct bodily position
in order to achieve the maximum amount
of results
because supposedly if you sat in the
lotus position
which is a cross-legged position where
your feet are propped up on your thighs
don't ask me to do it now amen
when i was a little bit more pliable as
a 20 year old
uh it was more possible but and then
with your back erect
and and it's very important too for you
to have your
hands in a certain what's called a mudra
m-u-d-r-a because then supposedly
the energy flow is like a completed
circuit but this also represents
something
the forefinger represents atman which is
the individual
soul and the thumb represents
brahman which is what's termed the
oversoul
which is an impersonal life force
not a personal god that you pray to but
an impersonal life force that you
meditate
on and seek to awaken within yourself
until you come to a point of realization
and that
self-realization is
the realization that you are god
in a certain aspect of hinduism not all
hindus
approach it that way but those who
believe in what's called
adveda vedanta which is the belief
that the universe is an emanation of god
so everything has a divine essence
so the position is extremely important
because this is an invocation to brahman
to come and fully manifest within the
individual meditator
but in the bible the position
is not relevant at all the first time
you find
meditation mentioned in the bible is
genesis 24
verse 63 and that's when isaac
who is the son of abraham walks out into
a field to meditate
in the evening okay and so he's just
walking through the field and i think
that's similar
to the idea expressed in genesis where
adam walked with god in the garden
and later on it talked about enoch walk
with god
and abraham walked with god and it's a
very
at ease conversant kind of connective
relationship because
real meditation is not mechanical
it's not manipulative it's not monotone
or monotonous or mundane it's
relational and all the eastern
approaches to meditation that i was
involved in
are very mechanical and it treats
god like just a force that you can
manipulate
with the right incantation mike
forgive me for interrupting that's what
they taught in the star wars series
the force was this pantheistic
energy that you know was inside of
everything
and that's that was the goal was to
connect with that
but i've often told people that
would you try to deepen your
relationship with your wife or your
husband
that way would you go into a room sit
crosslated
and close your eyes and then chant in a
monotone way
i love you honey i love you honey
for hours at a time because you're
racking up points in a sense
the more you say it the more
uh benefit supposedly you get by the
time you say that a dozen times
your wife will leave the room and call
somebody
who can get a psychiatrist over to the
house right away
my husband's gone crazy uh and
and if we would not approach
relationship
with a fellow human being in that
mechanical kind of way
why do we think god is less than that
because god is a person god does not
enforce god as a person
and i think that's very important to see
and the very central theme of the bible
is god is love i mean amen
i think it kind of sets apart like i'm
not too sure if you actually even
speak of other gods in that way like
that god really loves me you know do
they do they talk like that in the
eastern culture
not really in that way warmth
that you just expressed that but some
far eastern believers are dualistic
where they believe that god exists as
separate from
he's just wonderful to a degree they
still believe there's a divine essence
within them
but say krishna devotees but they still
approach meditation from a very
mechanical standpoint uh for instance um
in in christian in fact let me let me
look this up
because i want to get the i want to get
the exact figures
while you're doing that i i think it's
really neat that god
doesn't require us to come to him in
that way
that there isn't a well i just didn't do
it good enough
you know what i mean like like we have
the ability to just just
utter a uh a thought or utter lord help
me
you know and it's like all of a sudden
god can
manifest in a big way in your life it's
not that i did those things
this way and this way and this way and
then so that determined god's help to me
you know do you know what's sad the
jewish religion
at the time when christ came the first
time it had become very much like that
yeah mechanical
very mechanical not for all of them
but for a large percentage of the jewish
people it had become just a ritual
yeah it's like did you wash your hands
did you do it three times did you take
this did you do this did you bow so many
times
and jesus was like they have a form
but there's no power they do not they
don't know me
anymore yeah yeah and it's
actually much much simpler and much more
profound and beautiful
when you see the availability of
relationships
but i was mentioning the krishna
devotees
and last time i went to los angeles by
the way
i was blessed to be able to spend about
an hour talking to the head
of the krishna consciousness movement in
north america are they down there in
venice beach
no they're there there was a hare
krishna there was a temple there
was a temple right there by the beach
that i remember i lived around there
when i was down there and i always see
them you know with the little
clanking things as they'd walk down the
street and they and they sing the hare
krishna chain
uh which is hari krishna krishna krishna
krishna
and that's called the maha mantra and
they're supposed to say that
a hundred and eight times with each
round in fact they have
beads that they use mala to kind of keep
track
yeah like the catholic rosary to make
sure
that they do it 108 times and they're
supposed to do that
a total of 16 times a day which is
1728 utterances
of that prayer wow i bet you there's an
app for that you know
it just kind of keeps track do it's for
you can i
can i throw something in this is so
weird because this was later on but
because you brought that up
when i was in the martial arts and in
tai chi
i i found something it was like
in especially especially in tai chi you
had what was called the long form which
the founder developed
in all of the five main styles of tai
chi
in the long form that he himself had
developed always had 108 movements
always even though these men were
were completely years apart from one
another maybe didn't even know each
other
but all of their long form which is a
number of postures that you go through
had 108 postures then you had the short
form which is one that he would do
or maybe one of his disciples developed
to kind of introduce people because the
long run was too long 108 movements
it was always 36 movements and this was
years after i'd made first black belt
and i was like
108 and 36 and then you talk about the
hindu beads well the buddhists
use the beads the muslims use the beads
the roman catholics use the beads what's
amazing is
is that the perfect string of beads
has 108 beads in it it's interesting
every one of those beads and i actually
found this from one of their websites
not just the beads but the 108
postures the 108 beads represent 108
deities
there are 36 deities that are said to be
uh
terrestrial and what world view are you
referring to
uh taoist or buddhism okay and then you
have 72
beads that are i'm sorry 36
or celestial and 72 are terrestrial
so you have heaven is 36 and the earth
is 72.
so when you're doing those beads or
you're doing those postures
in the posture like you said with the
hand position
it's invoking the deity every one of the
postures
in the ancient forms that were developed
by the taoist and buddhists
the actual posture was a mudra that you
were doing with your body
well in in in buddhist meditation i
think it's different
they have the cosmic hand mudra
and i think it's like that where they
some of them do it
yeah and and from what i was familiar
with
that represented the universe
and it's because of the hole there that
it's empty of any lasting
existence or value which was a basic
idea
in buddhism but it was it was amazing to
me that
you are invoking deities yeah
yeah yeah now all all of these practices
are in stark opposition to jesus
teaching
amen because in matthew chapter 6 verse
he said use not vain repetitions
like the heathen do yep why would he say
that
use not vain repetitions like the
heathen do because they think they'll be
heard for their much speaking so the
whole idea is that you
build up through the repetitions
that you do some type of
uh reward that can be returned to you
uh deliverance from the cycle of reverse
or something like that if you have
a certain number of millions of
repetitions of certain phrase
it might be enough to burn up all your
karma and release you from the cycle of
rebirth and it's all
a man-achieved goal of deliverance from
this
lower state but uh again
it's a vain way to approach a
relationship with god
you mentioned the serpent in the
beginning the whole goal of meditation
within the hindu framework was the
awakening of the kundalini
and probably we'll need to get into that
in just a minute didn't you have a
question
or a comment before we deviated from the
i just i just want to see if i remember
something correctly so okay you probably
will
in the shaolin temple the hall of wooden
dummies yes
aren't there 108 i believe so yeah that
they have to pass through before they
get i believe
their arms branded i believe they're
well i'll have to double check
it's been a while so do you know of any
rhyme or reason why 108 like is there
those are the deities oh okay just like
you're explaining the 36 and the 74
yes so that's why all of them
had that 108 is because those are the
and who knows i don't know this but what
if we were to get to heaven and find out
oh yeah well those were the top
generals in the satanic forces i mean
who knows what that is
yeah satan's got to make them feel like
you're being elevated because that's
what he's been trying to do to everybody
since he fell
well all the postures in yoga or at
least
the majority of postures and yoga
actually are
dedicated to individual deities yes i've
read that
yeah i just looked it up it is
definitely exactly
108 and the wooden men yeah the michelin
uh wooden men hall and paul mentioning
you know they
they sacrificed they did not know what
they were sacrificing to but they were
sacrificing to demons you know
i'm sure behind um some of these things
that
other people will you know worship and
consider you know
if you peel back the onions oh go ahead
i'm sorry no i was just gonna get back
to my what mike was saying you know the
the vain repetition it's like
what a miserable existence you have to
say something over and over again and
and
so contrary to the way god is it's
mind numbing i said it once yeah
it happens it's done i don't have to
repeat a statement i'm making to you
right a thousand times on this uh
interview or this broadcast or whatever
you want to call this
this discussion among us uh because
you're a thinking
rational human being usually and what
and how much more is god
right right even us you know yeah do you
know what's interesting mike when you
were saying that
um there's another there's another
potential there
by using vain repetition it also helps
to induce
an altered state of consciousness which
is what satan wants any it's like when
you breathe and you breathe and you
breathe in you breathe out
it enters you into an altered state of
consciousness but do you know
you remember when elijah went up on
mount carmel
and the prophets of baal were trying to
call on bail to get him to answer
it was all day over and over and over
again and finally they got to the point
where they weren't
getting an answer so they started
cutting themselves
and the whole time elijah's sitting
there and he's thanking
these poor men and you know what he did
he prayed
god answered right yeah and so
he didn't have to earn it through
repetition amen
my heart goes out though to these
committed
buddhist monks suspended lives in a
monastery
from early ages sometimes their parents
take them to the monastery
and and their whole goal is reaching
nirvana
and they go through tremendous
self-sacrifice so the wandering
sadhus in india who in like manner spend
their whole lives
meditating and doing various yogic
approaches
to try and reach god consciousness i
admire their commitment i don't agree
with their conclusions
right but i admire the commitment of
anyone
who's reaching for something higher than
just the mundane existence of living in
this world
if they had that kind of commitment to
the falls imagine what they will be
like when they find christ because they
will be
it's like paul he was so dead set
against christ but when he was
one to christ he turned the world upside
down right right
so so there's people hopefully that will
be watching
this program that are involved in these
kinds of meditation
and hopefully you will find out that all
you have to do is call on the name of
jesus invite him to be lord of your life
you can be born again which is
an experience where you receive a new
spirit
infused with god's spirit amen and then
all of a sudden you're
aware of the presence of god in your
life
it is an experience of awareness but
it's not
self-awareness it's not self-deception
in the name of
awareness it's an awareness of the
reality of god in your life that comes
when you go through the door
because jesus meant what he said in john
14 6
when he declared i am the way the truth
and the life and no man comes to the
father but by me
and he also said all whoever came before
me are thieves and robbers that's right
and i thought that was a kind of harsh
statement when i first read it when i
first became a follower of jesus
and then i realized take buddha for
instance
i don't believe buddha was intentionally
robbing jesus the messiah of his
position
as world teacher i think buddha felt
that his conclusions were correct but by
virtue
of positioning him himself in a place
of influence and leading others into
what he taught
was the truth then he was robbing
jesus who would come what 500 years
later
of a position that only he had the right
to fill
as the teacher of all mankind so
again we need to realize that it's only
through jesus
but i do want to mention and i'm glad
you've got that on the screen
the picture of all the chakras and we
may get into chakra meditation later on
but when i would meditate as a follower
of hinduism slash sikhism the guru i
studied under was actually a sikh who
embraced a lot of hindu concepts which
made some sikhs doubt his claim
to being a leader in sikhism but uh
anyway the whole purpose was to awaken
this
serpent power that we referenced a while
ago well what is the
kundalini what is the serpent power
supposedly according to that teaching
it is a coiled energy dormant
at the base of the spine that through
meditation
is aroused and like a striking serpent
it rises up through the seven chakras
and then it in a sense strikes
the crown chakra where shakti and sheba
which are two deities female and male
deity
are united and that's when a person
achieves
god-consciousness isn't shiva the
goddess
of jesus is the god the god
of the destruction yeah yeah yeah the
destroyer
and that's the one where you have the
circle and it's many arms is that shiva
yeah it is the dance of sheba the dance
of sheba
is the the cycles of the inner universe
from manifestation to destruction
and the cycle of every human being from
birth to death and then rebirth and he's
called the lord of yoga
but the reason he is revered is that
through
death then you can evolve
to the next birth and eventually
be delivered from the whole cycle of
rebirth that yeah that's the way they
look at and they don't realize
death is a result of sin right yeah we
yeah so but and i suppose like if time
were to go on and on and on
right in this line of thinking then all
of a sudden there'd be
millions and millions of gods
oh yeah well there are 330 million
gods that's what they say hinduism but
each person is a potential god
so these are all people that have
achieved this higher state of existence
and now not all uh i don't know that
all the deities in hinduism would be
considered
like they were once human or something
you know kind of yeah i i don't think
that's the case but
but each individual has that potential
of ultimately achieving that well in in
buddhism you're more familiar with that
the whole goal is to become a buddhi
yourself
right yeah and and what buddha did was
he became connected to the universe he
became one with the universe
and uh so that's the whole goal or at
least that's what his claim was
yeah and the thing is is that goal of
being one with the universe means you
become one with god because the god they
worship is a pantheistic god so when you
become one with
this force this energy that they call
god
you become god and we've got quotes
later on i'll get in
into that but this uh this talk is
supposed to be about meditation
so uh i thought it would be good if we
went over the eight
kinds of meditation that you find
in the eastern religions be it taoism
or uh hinduism or buddhism
number one is breath meditation number
two is gentry meditation
number three is chakra meditation number
four is mantra meditation
and that's funny because a lot of people
will say oh that's my mantra and they
don't even realize what they're saying
is not a good thing can you give me a
little breakdown of what
what what does it mean to be have breath
meditation well i thought we'd do that
after i mentioned the whole list then
i could go back and and pick each one
out and go deeper into it
number five is sound meditation
number six is movement meditation which
you'll be much more familiar with
uh number seven is visualization
meditation
and number eight is silent meditation
and breath meditation is called the
entry level
of meditation it's the simplest to do
and so they teach that anyone can do it
and and this is the the deception of it
that if you were to
do that if you were just somebody with a
lot of chaos in your life
and you want to calm your mind and
you're stressed to the max
and you read some little booklet that
says all you've got to do is
sit down close your eyes and concentrate
on exhaling
and inhaling that's going to give you a
semblance of peace
well i've often heard of that in terms
of if you can't sleep at night
if you actually be conscious of your
breath
in and out you can actually put you to
sleep that's how i've heard it
but is that kind of the same thing like
it's like it's similar okay it's it's
the
practice of mindfulness uh from buddhism
and then
there there are a lot of related
concepts in all the different religions
but supposedly by concentrating on the
inflow and outflow of
breath then you're you're
becoming more conscious of the source of
life
and and you're reducing what they call
monkey chatter
yes in your mind where you're getting
your mind off of
all these issues and events and
pressures
and demands in your life and you're just
getting focused
on your breath now people think hey
this is working because they feel what
seems to be
peace after i would chant and we'll get
to that more in just a minute hopefully
but after i would chant for an hour or
two hours i would come out of it and i
would be like
buzzed i i feel this energy
level where i thought hey i'm really
connecting with this force this
power this brahman uh deity
in hinduism because i felt energized by
it well first of all
hyperventilation is going to make you
feel irritated
and and in kundalini yoga they had
something called the breath of fire
where you would actually inhale and
exhale very fast
for a certain amount of times and then
you would hold your breath
and it would like send this energy flow
through
well that's just that's going to happen
to anybody
that breathes heavy but what the mistake
they
make is that in hinduism and maybe you
can give me
the the buddhist term they call it prana
everything is saturated with prana prana
is the elemental life form
and prana exists in the air
as well as in thought life in intangible
things and in any material things and
living things especially you find prana
so
when you're doing a breathing meditation
you're actually intensifying your level
of prana and to them that's synonymous
with coming into oneness with god
because to them that's inseparable the
life that's in every
creature the life that's in every plant
the life that's in every human being
is in that world view the life of god
you just have to learn how to tap into
it like in in the buddhist and in the
taoist
they actually break that thing that the
hindus call prana they break it into
three separate
uh parts so you have chi
and then you have shin which is spirit
in mind and then you have something
called
jing which is chi or prana
except it's formed into like a chemical
essence
that's in every living thing so
but the thing that that is scary about
it is is that
people will say like you just repeated
um
it works well yeah but what are you
opening the door to
you know if i'm not sleeping well at
night i turn to psalms
and i i claim god's promise i will lay
you will lay me down to sleep and i will
rest tonight in peace
he gives his beloved sleep i believe i
believe his promises
and i asked the lord lord take my
thoughts
captive to christ and the bible says
that let this mind be in
each of us that was in christ jesus so
by claiming his promise
god who is in his word his spirit is in
his word
comes into me and it does what his word
says
by the same token satan knows the rules
to that game
so if the if the hindus or the buddhists
or the taoists say no do this
breathe this many times and say this and
i yield myself and obey
that opens the door for his spirits to
come in and do his work well that's what
happened when i meditated on
the kundalini and when i would feel this
power rising up through me
and one time i went into white light and
a couple of times i had astral
projection
experiences of what appeared to be what
seemed to be i have a different
interpretation of it now amen
actually what happened to me and it did
not become apparent to me until
after i was born again is i became
demon-possessed
yes and these demons impersonating this
kundalini power possess
me and were very obliging in
giving me supernatural experiences to
make me think
i'm achieving my goal i know i'm getting
there
i'm arriving and it just opens the door
to all kinds of mental and
and emotional problems in fact the gurus
warn you
that if you prematurely awaken the
kundalini
you could go crazy you could go insane
you could
awaken dark occultic powers you could
have visions of demons
and so they warn you that this could be
a very negative experience
but there has never been a case in the
bible where someone had
a real encounter with the true god
and it was detrimental amen
yeah and in fact the opposite is almost
the truth because
those demoniacs when they came to jesus
they were flailing all around and mad
men basically
and the second they they had christ in
their lives and
you know opened their hearts to him it
was peace and calm and this and that so
so yeah the kundalini thing is just kind
of a lot of the opposite type it's like
this
more energy and more you know things
that could be chaotic in your life
rather than you get this peace
it's not the peace of god in yoga and
meditation it's not the peace of god
it's a soulish kind of peace it can be a
demonic counterfeit of peace
but when you experience the prince of
peace
that's right which is one of jesus names
he's sar shalom he's the prince of peace
and he fills you with his peace not just
a peace that comes from god he said
not as the world gives give i unto you
but my peace i give unto you
that's an indescribable peace it's peace
that passes understanding
far greater than i ever got by sitting
cross-legged and chanting the mantra for
an hour
amen so true amen i want to kind of
bring this
to a practical level for our viewing
audience because
maybe they've never been involved in
yoga or the martial arts or whatever
you guys are probably familiar with this
app called calm
yeah i've heard of it you've seen it
advertised i've even
seen um they have products in mainstream
stores like walmart or target or
something right
so they build themselves as
if you just google calm
the number one app for meditation and
sleep
okay and you go to their website and you
know
it's like find your calm our goal is to
help you improve your health and
happiness
what can we help you with today improve
sleep quality reduce stress or anxiety
improve focus self-improvement or
something else and you kind of select
that and it
it guides you you know on what what you
need to start doing
so you go to the help center it's like
well well what
what is this really like what what are
we doing because this is focused on
breathing that's what this app is doing
is helping you focus on
the way you're breathing and relaxing
and all of this kind of stuff
and they you look on their this is from
their website what meditate
what meditation techniques does calm use
because you could have somebody out
there they they pick this up at the
store
they they're scrolling through on their
phone they download it yeah
i want to sleep better at night i want
to be more relaxed you know
they're not going down to the local yoga
you know training center or whatever
they're just like oh yeah i'm going to
use an app
what what can it help me do so you look
on their website and it says this and
want you guys to jump in on this it says
some of our sessions
include introduce specific practices
okay
now before i read the rest of the
sentence i'm going to read the last
sentence
all of our teachings are universal and
non-religious
okay that's what they say they're
universal and non-religious
now i'm going to finish some of our
sessions and introduce
specific practices that lie within the
umbrella of mindfulness
such as vipassana or insight practice
and loving kindness okay it means to see
things as they really are
so i just look at the meaning of it is
okay and it says
special super scene it's a buddhist term
that is often translated as
insight and then mentions some guy
paulie cannon describes it as or maybe a
holy book describes it as one of two
qualities of mind which is developed
in buddhist meditation the other being
samantha
so they said how can it be non-religious
and yet incorporated if it's coming from
as a marketing scheme right it's a
marketing scheme so
you know you can pick something up at
the store
and think no big deal you know i'm just
doing this to relax and then all of a
sudden you'll be kind of being
slowly it's like like you just said the
breathing
is the introductory experience and here
is the basis of the deception
breath is synonymous with life force
within the new age or far eastern
framework of thinking
but our natural breath is totally
different than the breath of god
amen in christianity and that's where
you have two kinds of life in fact the
bible uses two different greek words
uh for instance jesus said take no
thought for your life
what you shall eat and what you shall
drink that's the word suke
p s p-s-u-c-h-e su-k
but then when he said he who believes on
me has everlasting
life it's a different word it's the word
zoe
z-o-e which means divine life god life
resurrection life and so there's a
difference between the two and
and that's really important to see
because even some christians
don't understand that when they do
breath meditation
they think they're breathing in the
presence of god i've met some people
that did christian yoga
talked with them and they thought that
breathing like that was an
intensification of a realization that
they're breathing in the presence of god
but
it's oxygen and nitrogen amen and other
gaseous vapors
and i have a favorite acrostic for yoga
y-o-g-a
you only get air you can't
you can't breathe your way into a
relationship with god
in the upper room after jesus rose from
the dead
the bible said he breathed on his
disciples
and said receive the holy spirit amen
implying that the breath that he just
breathed was something they didn't have
yet
amen and it was a restoration of what
adam lost in the beginning
because god breathed into this clay form
that he had just created and adam became
a
living soul so
what happened when he fell he was still
a soul
but he was a dead soul subject to all
kinds of
death dealing attitudes like depression
and hatred and
jealousy and and anger and things like
that and lust
the soul died the breath of god took its
flight or departed from adam and it was
only restored
after jesus paid the price on the cross
and so
that needs to be emphasized that the
breadth of a human being
is not divine in essence and i want to
bring out the fact that some
popular christian songs that i love i
sing these songs and it moves my heart
and yet they've got lines in them that
are far eastern
in their interpretation like reckless
love i'm sure you've heard reckless love
i'm not slamming the guy that wrote the
song i think he really loves god
but he said before i took a breath you
breathed your life in me you have been
so so kind to me well wait a second
that's not true
the breath of god didn't come into me
until the day i was
saved and born again and that's when god
revitalized my soul
with the entrance of his spirit into my
life
it didn't happen prior to birth and
there's a couple of other songs like
you ever have you ever sung great are
you lord
it's your breath in our lungs so
we pour out our praise we pour out our
praise it's your breath
in our lungs that's not true
god's breath is not confined to my
lungs it saturates and permeates my
spirit and my
soul so i believe that's something
yeah that's interesting we've only
gotten to meditation process number one
yeah which is breath meditative yeah so
we can move on quickly but you start to
see how
some of these influences have actually
you know found its way into all kinds of
different pieces of life
not knowing where you know the basis of
these eastern
ideas are coming from and not
understanding them
you would hear a song like that and i
didn't really even put that two
things together you know but now that
i've understand
with you guys explaining to me where
this is basically going
now i can see that there actually is oh
yeah
and the writer's probably didn't intend
anything wrong about it
it just sounds poetically nice to say it
that way right
well shall we move on to number two you
know
you leave yantra meditation uh is
meditating on a geometric design
and and the whole purpose in
any of these meditation processes is
to empty the mind which is contrary to
the biblical approach and of course
we'll cover that later
but staring at a geometric design like a
yantra
has a hypnotic effect and usually
there's something called a bendu
which is a little point right in the
middle of the yantra
that represents a specific deity like
shiva or
or vishnu or some other deity
and so you're trying to connect with
that deity
by focusing on that point until you just
block out everything else it's like a
portal
into a mystical experience but again
what are you opening your heart and mind
up to
when you do that yeah do you know what's
interesting um
a lot of people probably don't even
realize that they're doing it
but a lot of books you'll see it'll have
an o and it has a dot in the center of
every o
on the cover of the book that that's
like what we see at the washington
monument you've got if you look down
at it you have a circle with a dot in
the center
in taoism the yin and yang
symbol it originally was a circle and
you see that with the oro boris you know
the serpent
you know swallowing its tail but it was
originally an oral boris and then they
say that
that split into two and when it split
into two
it was a circle with the dot in the
center and then they say
that formed or transformed
and became the yin and yang to where
you had dualistic light and darkness
and now they're saying we're at the
point where everything's going to come
back
to one so they're trying to bring
everyone back that's what all these
processes
mechanical processes are all about and
and that's something i like to emphasize
over and over again that if meditation
techniques
are mechanical mindless monotonous
monotone manipulative
mundane magical
or even overly mystical they're probably
not the right approach amen
because again with regard to the yantra
y-a-n-t-r-a would you
have a geometric design representing
your wife or your husband
with a little dot in the middle and try
to deepen your relationship with that
person
by staring at this dot for hours at a
time and she's sitting here trying to
get your attention
and you're like leave me alone talk to
me honey i'm becoming one with you hon
you know what's interesting about this
is i'm listening to you guys talk like
i i can see these kind of connections to
christianity or to god
like like god asked us to place our eyes
upon the cross
amen right and it's like here that cross
means something to us when we look at it
we understand what god putting himself
on that cross
means to us and it's has a transforming
power but here it's like
look at a pattern look at an empty
pattern that really
for the lack of whatever doesn't really
mean anything to anybody
and it's like it's like it's like almost
taking that and it's just a counterfeit
of what god's
really wanting us to do and it's sad
it's very sad
that people devote themselves so
intensely
to a process like that and it's all in
vain
it's all impacted you know if you can
mike while you're on the
the yantras recently and i don't know
when it first started but recently in
the past couple of years
you can go into bookstores everywhere
and you'll find
yantra coloring books made for adults
that's right
but they're hindu if you look at the
sources where they're coming from
and people go oh it's for stress they'll
tell you on the book this is for stress
you just color this
but it is those patterns that is to
enter you
help you enter into an altered state of
consciousness and
that would sound ridiculous to some
people but
each one of those yantras represents an
individual deity
that's right a fallen angel yeah or
just a creation of someone's imagination
because where did all these deities come
from why embrace
a belief in some deity and you don't
even know the source
of its existence you don't know who
brought the myth forth
and began to proclaim the existence of
this deity
but you just blindly accept it i know
there was a certain point in my life
where i decided
and it was both good and bad but when i
had a near-death experience at the age
of 18
i decided you know i'm gonna seek for
god until i find him but i'm going to
wipe the slate clean
and any kind of religious influence i've
had all my upbringing
i'm not going to be biased in any way
i'm just going to open myself
up to everything and of course i got
sidetracked
in wrong ways in bad ways uh shall we go
to chakra meditation yes
number three chakra meditation
there are seven chakras according to
hindus but then buddhists teach four
chakras or some buddhist teachers yeah
but they they also it's weird because
they've incorporated so much
so like when i was taught it we were
taught all seven oh really yes
well say buddha came up in a hindu
culture and buddhism was actually a
reform movement
that's in hinduism that's right where uh
he rejected the hindu deities
and some buddhist uh groups now
also practice idolatry and yes
and uh worship of those idols which
buddha himself would have been
strongly against well at the shaolin
temple which i know
uh keith is familiar with they had
something called the
hall of the mahavari and there were
three
huge buddhist idols that were in there
and
it was all idolatry that was common so
wait a minute buddha
was against idolatry he was against the
whole pantheon of hindu gods and he was
against the caste system
he was not of the brahmin caste and
his family was of the the warrior cast
and and so he felt that was an
incorrect view of the way society should
be
so he started as a so did guru nanak the
founder of sikhism
he was born into a hindu predominantly
hindu culture
and and started out as a reform
movement within hinduism of course sikhs
would say no he got a revelation
it wasn't reforming hinduism it was
something altogether different but
anyway uh so we can
uh meditate on those individual chakras
if we're a yoga devotee
and supposedly you can align your
chakras
now chakras have never been proven
they there is no scientific process to
prove their existence
the guru i studied under used to say
that
chakras were imaginary and nothing else
it was just an aid to meditation
so if a proponent of chakra meditation
said it was just
imaginary why would anyone actually
believe in them
right and you can see by this
uh image that each one of the chakras
represents a
different characteristic
like the heart chakra in the middle of
the chest
is for love or healing and then
the throat chakra is for communication
etc and when you meditate on those
particular chakras those
uh qualities can be enhanced in your
life supposedly
well who wouldn't want more wisdom who
wouldn't want more awareness who
wouldn't want more spirituality
the crown chakra is spirituality and and
so you get sucked into this
but meditating on a swirling ball of
energy is not going to make you a more
loving person
connecting with the god who is love and
you quoted that scripture a while ago
that god
is love and he who dwells in love dwells
in god
that's going to infuse your spirit with
love in fact
jesus prayed that he said father the
glory you've given me
i have given them the words you've given
me i have given them
that the love with which you have loved
me may be
in them he actually prayed that we would
receive
this infilling of love and that's one
amazing thing about becoming a christian
and a follower of jesus and having a
true born-again experience
i've seen very hateful people become
very loving people totally
uh and so again this is too mechanical
it's too monotonous mundane
mystical magical and
and as to be honest with you i think
it's ridiculous
to meditate on some supposed swirling
ball of energy that maybe
happens to be turning the wrong way and
you've got to adjust it through
meditation where it will spin the right
direction
and then i have more peace i have more
love
no that's like entering some kind of
formula
into a computer program i see it a bit
like a ouija board
like scientifically that ouija board is
literally made up of
of whatever the plastic game pieces are
there's really no
scientific explanation of why it does
what it does
but you playing with it gives the
demonic realm
the ability to manifest itself through
that game that's a great
point so this is kind of like how i see
that is it's like you're giving a
visual cue to okay i'm i'm believing in
you guys and
i'm giving you license to come and you
know absolutely manifest let me
interject something because when you
were talking about the seven
chakras um it was interesting because
in the taoist and shaolin has a blend
of taoism and buddhism now um even with
the t within the past hundred years
there's been the shaolin temple is where
all your martial arts run
from right um in the shaolin
when you would when you would
concentrate you would meditate
and this is primarily the taoist way of
looking at it
they say that within the human body
there are two
primary channels for this universal
energy that they call chi
one is called the governing vessel which
starts at a point called the
the perineum which is down between the
anus
and the you know reproductive organs
it starts there and it travels up the
spine
until it reaches the crown chakra and
then it comes down
the nose and at a point right here at an
angle
behind the upper teeth that's the what
they call the governing vessel that's
what's represented by yong
the male from there the tip of the
tongue
you have the conception vessel which is
said to travel down the front of the
body
and meet at the perineum so within
whenever we were breathing you would
visualize
you were told by your instructor to
the energy traveling up the governing
vessel
on breath in and then breath out it
would travel down the conception vessel
or in reverse because you would do
reverse breathing sometimes
but the whole point there was to get
this energy
flow going through the body and then
once you got that moving
you were told to begin opening those
chakras like
doorways and like it was funny because
you said that in the hinduism and the
yoga
it was a spinning sphere or a ball
think about what is out there in outer
space it's a spinning ball
every one of the planets there's seven
primary chakras originally the ancient
pagans
they worshiped seven celestial bodies
wow
seven primary the sun was
the male the moon was the female and
then you had
mars mercury jupiter venus and saturn
that's shocking because when i first saw
that it started
dawning on me everything that they
worshipped
was gods those chakras
were these planetary gods that the roman
names of the planets come from deities
yes yes and the greeks had them the
romans had them mars the egyptians
that's right jupiter one of the chief
gods venus the goddess of love
yeah passion it was it was immorality
illicit
yeah not real love but you know when you
said that i was like
you know it all comes back
to idolatry everything that they were
doing
was idolatry and what do they experience
when they leave their body in meditation
what did i experience the few times that
happened to me
uh i believe and i may be wrong on this
because it's theoretical and there's
nothing to absolutely prove it
but there is some indication
in scripture of what it might be because
we are told there's a third heaven
which is paradise where god dwells where
paul yeah
paul talked about he went he was taken
up into the third heaven so there's
three heavens
i personally believe that the first
heaven is the atmosphere around the
earth
and the physical cosmos beyond so it's
the physical heaven
i believe of course in the third heaven
and hope to one day
uh experience it to the fullest amen but
what's this second heaven
and it dawned on me that satan is called
the prince of the power of the air
he does not rule in hell like almost all
your christian plays
he's not on a throne in hell sending out
demons from there
he's the prince of the power of the air
well you don't see him jumping
from one cloud to the next there must be
a concentric
realm that is just like we can't see
infrared or ultraviolet light and yet
it's part of the spectrum
there must be another heaven
a second heaven beyond the first heaven
where there's satanic activity demonic
activity and even angelic clashes with
demons now they're roaming back and
forth but we can't see that
right yeah and so when these gurus and
swamis and yoga devotees and different
individuals and martial arts
practitioners
do their meditation they claim to have
genuine authentic supernatural
experiences what's happening they're
penetrating possibly
the second heaven where demonic
deception
is inevitable they cannot get to god
they cannot get to the third heaven
because the only door that leads to a
relationship with god
is jesus amen and and the difference the
huge difference is
all these meditative practices are men's
attempt to reach ultimate reality
but jesus was god's attempt to reach us
and so it's not reaching up to attain a
level of consciousness right
it's god coming down to your level right
and fixing the problem
right so that is interesting because in
the occult world especially
in like um you know the esoteric things
like the kabbalah
they often talk about these different
realms that when they cross
over each other that you can have access
in between that realm and that realm can
now have access to you
and you know it's kind of interesting
just listening to that and
and a lot of demonic deception is
involved in all of that but
but i wonder what has perpetuated the
idea that you can have these out-of-body
experiences
and it's because it's a counterfeit
experience of something
god has been known to do he did
and apparently in paul's life or whoever
paul was talking about
but is counterfeit and counterfeit can
only be a reproduction a false
reproduction of something that is
true and the peace that you feel in
meditation is a counterfeit piece
compared to peace amen but what about
mantra meditation mantra
meditation is as we've already covered
the repetition
of a certain statement like om let me
take om for instance
om is actually stretched out into three
sounds a-u-m and each one of those
sounds
represents a different deity
which is uh unknown to a lot of people
that chant
the word om but i believe a is
representative
of um let's see i think a was
brahma the creator god the you
is vishnu the preserver god and the m
is shiva the destroyer god
and so when you chant om once again like
you said
it's actually an invocation to these
gods to come and supernaturally manifest
take you over and manifest within you
you know it's an invitation for demons
to the lord actually told us
in the old testament i believe it was in
deuteronomy he said
don't take the names of these gods upon
your lips
when we're discussing it that's
different because we're exposing the
darkness like we're supposed to
but he's saying don't say these names
because they'll come
right you know if i've got a record
album stuck away and i go i don't listen
to that anymore but i don't want to get
rid of it because it means a lot to me
of acdc
well they go i've got a right to be
there if i'm
chanting the names of these gods they
will show up
you've invited them and again
it is a way of numbing the mind because
when i would chant
the main chant i would chant and i don't
really like repeating it
from the reasons you just mentioned but
for the sake of this program
i would chant ek omkar satnam siriwa
guru
and if you were to translate that into
understandable english it would probably
say
something like there is one god truth is
his name
and the great spirit is our teacher
which is all true right that sounds good
within a
biblical framework of interpretation
that's right
but when a hindu says there is one god
it's all-inclusive
interpretations of the nature of god are
are useful
and helpful and they're all correct but
when a christian says there is only one
god we're talking about
one interpretation of the nature of god
the triune nature of god
father son and holy spirit and these
three are one
god so that's how close you can get to
the truth and
still be in the darkness of deception
you know the devil likes to do that too
because
you'll be right on the path and he'll
just veer you off just
one step and you're this is light
everything else even if it's one inch or
if it's 10 feet
off that path is darkness yeah because
if you think of it like
um we've used this illustration before
of two ships you know and you turn a
ship
ever so slightly i mean it could be a
degree half a degree
quarter of a degree over the course of
time that ship's going to end up way
over here
but in the beginning it doesn't seem
like it's at least it's just one
direction it's just the focus is
slightly off shifted
and the last phrase meant the great
spirit is our teacher
the middle phrase satnam means truth is
his name which is a favorite
way of referring to god in sikhism i
mean even that i am the way the truth
into life it's like
it is his name yeah but what are you
saying truth is
right and of course a sikh
uh recognizes different things as being
the truth
than a christian we we recognize the
need for putting your faith in the
crucifixion
of the lord jesus where he became sin
for us that's not in the sikh world
at all and yet that's fundamentally
important in the christian worldview
and most importantly that three days
later he rose from the dead
amen so again you can even say
truth is his name well that's really a
title that's not a name
anyway so what would you say we know his
personal name
as jesus or yeshua the hebrew form of it
what would you say to a christian
martial artist or somebody that wanted
to get involved in this and said well
i'm saying these names and i'm thinking
of this god
uh i would say to a christian don't ever
be in the room
where people are chanting the word om
i've had christians tell me well when i
go to yoga class and they start
chanting the real i just think of jesus
that's like
sitting in an idol temple while idol
worship is going on
and you just close your eyes and think
of the true god
is god going to be happy with that no we
do find a place in the old testament
where they tried to put the ark of the
covenant
in the temple of a philistine god named
dagon amen
which was half fish and half man and
they came back the next day
and their god had fallen on his face
eating dirt
amen sad if you had to pick your god ups
because he'd fallen you know it's funny
because in in deuteronomy 18
you know like the question you asked he
actually says thou
shalt not learn to do after the
abominations of those nations
don't learn the ways of the heathen he
says in jeremiah chapter 10.
so people can say well yeah but i'm
worshiping god this way
that happened with jeroboam and he said
in that same passage but you shall be
perfect with the lord your
amen and part of achieving christian
perfection is
extricating yourself from all of these
non-biblical
amen approaches amen because god lists
things in there like witchcraft
and and contacting the dead necromancy
and things like that and he said
do not involve yourself in these
practices i think it even says in there
don't even observe them doing that not
even that you're engaging in it or
you're in
you know whatever don't watch them and
their worship ceremonies you know
right yeah uh because they're they're
you'll be ensnared
yeah if you're not really strong
spiritually you can be contaminated
like they had that uh ceremony of the
opening
of the uh tunnel over and forward
yes i saw that yeah that was like a
full-blown
luciferian worship i watched just a few
minutes of it and i was like i got to
cut this off
within the past couple of years i claim
the protection of the blood of jesus
no i mean there was like world leaders
that showed up over there
oh yeah the head of germany the head of
switzerland the head of
uh i mean it's like the you know the
cern thing with the big shiva out front
of the cern and it's like
what yeah i know what is that you know
uh but that's that's
telling everybody together but let's
i'll tell you what i think we've covered
chakra meditation
and mantra meditation because i've
already mentioned what jesus said using
vain repetitions like the heathen do and
the absurdity of trying to reach
god who is a person on a mechanical
level like that
but there's also something number five
called
sound meditation which i participated in
when i was in kundalini yoga
is it the dawning of things yeah
uh yogi bhajan would pull this big
mallet out and he had a great big
gong about this size and you'd lay flat
on your back
and just meditate on the third eye and
he'd hit that gong
over and over and the echo of it the
resounding echo
would resonate yeah it's like
vibrational
feeling of something infinite yeah and
it kind of helped you
transcend into thoughts that were
kind of more infinitely attached than
temporally attached
and get out of a temporal state of mind
into an infinite state of mind
but did it really help you reach god
absolutely not
but sound meditation is supposed to help
that
god does use sound though like
uh music is full of sound
yeah he's the creator of different
different notes different
lyrics can either be containers of
demonic influence
like the wrapper that just came out with
satan's shoes right i guarantee you you
listen to his rap music
and you're to get demonically infested
if you open your heart to it
right but there's christian music
that is truly full of the holy spirit
and so
sound does have power but not in a
mystical
mechanical manipulative magical way
it's just something that fills heaven
there's singing and worship and music
instruments in heaven so
why wouldn't god use them on earth right
and you know god is god is always like
come
let us reason together like right like
like let's cut
let me fill your heart and let me come
into you right it's this
very like intel like opening of your
mind or your heart too god
but when i see the devil's counterfeits
for that it's always dealing with the
senses
it's always like this feeling or this
thing that it's like
you know when that senses gets aroused
then it's like you're you're you're
achieving god i don't see god operating
like that
do you know in the shaolin temple um
they did the same thing
where they would use a gong uh during
parts of the meditation
and the gong and they would describe it
in different ways they would talk about
um the vibrational energy the resonance
of the frequency a lot of people that
get involved
which i like essential oils but it's an
oil it's an
oil but a lot of the companies will say
no no no this thing resonates at such a
certain frequency when you put it on
your body it helps to raise your
frequency
um right now on the internet there's all
kinds of things on youtube that'll say
you'll find it this is a high frequency
that you get to listen to for two hours
that
is supposed to help you spiritually get
closer to god and
they're new age websites but they're
saying
through sound we can connect you to god
so it's using the flesh to connect to
god rather than using the heart and the
mind good point
it's like the difference between ishmael
and isaac amen
isaac was my promise ishmael was by
flesh
right all of these are ishmael efforts
at
achieving oneness with god there's
nothing wrong with wanting to be one
with god but the method you use
is absolutely essential the method you
use also determines which god you become
one right
because if i use satan's method i'm
going to be joined to brahman or vishnu
or
whatever and you may not know it's the
poison of asps
that's right like you mentioned at the
beginning you may think this is a
wonderful heavenly nectar
but it's not well the next one is
movement
meditation and that's not something i'm
familiar with because i i always sat
motionless
when i did meditation in yoga
i have grown to appreciate
the passion of sufis i don't agree
with their worldview or what they teach
or their methods
but they're known as they're a strange
kind of new age sect of the
islamic faith yes and they're more
universal in their mindset they're not
exclusive like other
muslims are but they have this whirling
dance have you ever seen the whirling
dervishes or
the su and they wear these long white
robes and they'll dance with one hand
lifted up at least one sometimes two
toward the beloved they refer to god as
the beloved and i think they are
genuine lovers of god if you ever
read their love poems toward god it's
just
uh amazing the heart they have for god
and it just takes me back to the fact
that before i found god
by opening my heart to jesus i loved god
intensely
and there's a huge difference between
loving god
and knowing god you can love god from a
distance and yet
that barrier is still there that
cannot be bridged unless you use god's
approach his god-given approach that's
probably why he told them in the old
testament if they made an altar
not to make it with stones that were
it was shaped by man because that
represented a man-shaped approach to god
because he knew in his providence that
we would make them bigger and better and
more fancy and then we'd outline it with
gold and you know yeah
it just flows too of course that was
an old approach to god but he wanted
stones in their original
god shape amen so and so we've got to
find the way god
approves of but my point was
that's a kind of a movement meditation
because they're constantly
meditating on the names of god or the
names they attribute to god there's 99
names for god
in the islamic faith and not one of them
is father
not one of them is father because they
don't believe
that god can as a father actually enter
into you where you can be born again
we we have a friend that is um actually
was a muslim at one point in time and
and that was the one thing that he
kept mentioning was that there was no
father picture
in the quran it spoke of uh or you know
god was basically telling muhammad
you know the jews call me father and and
they they believe they're my children
but correct them i'm not their father
i'm not their son you're not my son
and that was just kind of an interesting
like revelation like what
you know that's interesting that that
the the love that we share with god is
that well you know what manner is this
that they would call me a child of god i
don't deserve this but yet that's how
that relationship is framed within
christianity i loved god
i i remember specifically sitting there
cross-legged meditating for hours
and then it would hit my heart and i
would break down weeping
and i would say god i love you i want to
know you
how long is it going to be i i didn't
know how easy it would be
let me let me read out of my book in
search of the true light
i i just want to show you the heart of
these sufis that do
movement meditation this is they're
one of their poets they are noted for
their sufi
love poems they write poems to god
and what what they think is god yeah
what they think is god
and of course in this poem is the name
allah
which i do not believe is the true god
and i don't believe in chrislam i don't
believe you can mix
christianity and ism but i want you to
see
the heart of people that are using these
methods
uh he says uh and this is a persian
devotional poem
by abdallah al ansari and he said
thou whose breath is sweetest perfume to
the spent
and anguished heart thy remembrance to
thy lovers
bringeth ease forever smart multitudes
like
moses reeling cry to earth's remotest
place
give me sight o lord they clamor seeking
to behold thy face
multitudes no man hath numbered lovers
and afflicted all
stumbling on the way of anguish allah
allah
loudly call and the fire of separation
sears the heart and burns the breast and
their eyes are
wet with weeping for a love that gives
not rest
oh god all other men are drunk with wine
the wine bearer is my fever their
drunkenness lasts but a night
while mine abides forever and of course
the analogy there
is people get drunk with religion but
uh he's totally enamored with the one
who gives it
but what gets to me is if they only
knew that love was in a bodily form when
jesus walked the earth amen
and they don't have to dance these
swirling whirling dances to try and
achieve oneness with god
whosoever shall call on the name of the
lord that's right do you know
it's sad because you know i love i love
people
because i was i was going to church
every week but i was worshiping another
god the other six days a week
didn't realize it i called him jesus but
it was not the same jesus as paul said
and this broke my heart because my wife
one of her best friends
was raised in turkey as a muslim and she
found christ
and when she gave her life to christ she
said
i saw what i had and she said i came to
this country and she said here in
america i heard people telling me that
allah and jehovah or yahweh are the same
she said it's not the same god
and she said i can show you one place
she said
in the quran it says allah cannot have a
son
right the scripture says in first john
whoever denies the father and the son
is antichrist she said so and if you
have not the son you have you have not
the father and christ said no man comes
to the father
except through me yeah even when they
were talking with jesus and said who who
is the father how do we know him and
he's like
yeah i've been hanging out with you come
on so yeah there's this
very distinct relationship between
father so it's like son that you can't
we have got to pray for
for you know our brothers and sisters
who don't even realize
satan is so subtle on how he tries to
deceive people
but didn't you do movement meditation in
which it is is this that kata is that
what you're talking about like well
it can be the but um tai chi
is specifically moving meditation
they tell you that's what it is so in
some of the cauda that we did i'm sure
keith had done some too
each movement like i remember the last
grand master that i trained under
um i'd been with him for a couple of
years and i came down to
to see him at his studio and he said you
know we're going to work on a new
um a new key gong pose and some of the
key gongs were stationary
you know where you just meditated with
your mind other key gongs you would go
through certain movements and you do
hold that pose for so many breaths and
then you would go to the next movement
and he told me i don't even remember the
name of it now but he told me this is
the one we're going to be working on
and he started going through it and i
was following him
and it was like i felt uncomfortable i
mean i just felt
uncomfortable like all the stuff i'd
been doing i should have been
uncomfortable but this one it was like
i did not feel right and i asked him i
said i said cjo which means grand master
or founder i said
what is the name of this one what does
it mean
and he looked at me and he said it means
iron buddha
so each of the poses that i was doing
you'd
hold this position or you'd hold this
position
and you'd breathe and you would
concentrate in each position
you would think and focus
on this energy moving through the body
and with tai chi
it was much more subtle because what
happens with tai chi
you teach them the motions this it's a
dance
you do this and then you flow and you
breathe and you get your breathing and
your body to connect
so that they're working synergistically
or
harmoniously and without knowing it
as the student gets to the point where
they've got the movements memorized and
then they've got the breathing
and coordination with their movements
then you come to them and you go okay
now this is what i want going on in your
head because they can't be focusing on
internal movement of energy when they're
just trying to remember the
the movements but after they get those
first two down
then you go to them and you say this is
what you're thinking
when that hand goes out this is what's
happening inside your body
so then they spend one year two years
three years doing that
and you can get done doing one of those
you know forms or codas and
like you said you feel like man i just
had a shot of you know super duper
caffeine i'm buzzing
and you know you can be drenched in
sweat after you know one form that might
take you five minutes
and what's the ultimate goal in tai chi
is it uh just the movement itself or do
they actually have a goal of
attaining a level of consciousness um at
the highest level again you don't tell
the beginners this it's almost like
freemasonry you know they never are told
the things that the guys at the 32nd or
33rd degree level are told
at the highest level it's immortality in
taoism
tai chi which is a taoist practice the
whole goal
is to move and open up all those chakras
to become enlightened crown chakra
third eye is open where you get
supernatural ability to
to foresee and then immortality
you become one with the universal energy
so has anybody ever achieved that
they claim yeah they claim i mean like i
think everyone still dies right
no but but that's not it you don't die
interesting
you die the flesh dies you become
you become part of the universe let's
just call them the immortals
yeah or ascended masters or like in star
wars
obi-wan he died right and then later on
luke
luke is sitting there talking to uh yoda
and yoda's oh it was qui-gon
i'm sorry um and and
obi-wan did the same thing he passes
away into death and then he comes back
and communicates
which the bible forbids yeah which which
the devil
obviously leaves that door open so that
you know you think you're
communicating with some ascended master
but but the thing is is even with that
they say they
they don't die they just put off this
flesh and they become universal they
become energy they become
god interesting well we've got
two more types of meditation
uh one is visualization number seven of
the eight
uh different types is visualization
meditation
didn't you do that so that was in
buddhism and in
taoism because you should start off well
it's like what we've talked about you
would visualize
oh right the flow of the energy the flow
of the energy the way that i was first
introduced to it was the first grand
master i was under and he
he told a group of us that were wanting
to learn how to
increase this energy within us this qi
he said this is what i want you to do
and don't anybody do this because if you
if you do this and you're listening
you're opening the door to satan and
evil spirits to come into your life i i
promise you
you don't have an option this cannot be
done without
channeling evil spirits but he told us i
want you to go into a room you've got to
be alone
it's got to be dark either have no
windows or it's got to be nighttime
black out all the the windows so it's
dark room
you sit in lotus position and we would
hold our hands but we would hold these
fingers
and you would hold these over your hands
a little bit different meaning yes
you'd hold it over your knees and you
would place a candle at a 45 degree
angle
in front of you on the floor and you'd
light that candle pitch black room
and he said you breathe internally
you're
sucking in through the nose breathing
out through the mouth connecting that
governing and conception vessel and
you're focusing on the flame and while
you're focusing on that flame
you're to imagine and visualize yourself
getting hotter
man it took forever i mean it was like
two years of doing that
every single week i mean you know and i
had to wait till either my wife is
asleep or you know
i had to go somewhere where i was alone
um
because i couldn't reveal to her what i
was doing she would have been like eric
this is of the devil
i mean like she knows and i'm like no no
no this is okay
when they tell you it's in the closet
black out the lights yeah and
stare at a candle for hours at a time
but you know
after two years of doing that you're
sitting there
and all of a sudden you're pouring sweat
and then it got to the point where
you know he would put us out on the
telephone pole that was horizontal
up off the ground you know three or four
feet off the ground and you'd stand
there in a horse stance
and i would just i would see the candle
in my head and i'd be like i'm hot
and then it got to the point to where
you could do that in 30 seconds
didn't even have to be i could be inside
running i'd be like i think i need to be
cold and i would will it
what i was told i was willing it to
happen and it would happen
but all that means is is that satan had
come
into me so much that when i said i want
this to happen
he did it and it they make you think
that you're the one controlling them
the genie that's in the bottle right but
you're really the vessel that the genie
is in
and it's controlling you not you
controlling that
yeah so again may i repeat
the statement that if a meditation
technique
is mechanical mindless monotonous
monotone magical manipulative or even
overly mystical like these yes it's not
right
amen it's not relational that's right
because true meditation
in fact we'll get into this in the next
uh
session but true biblical meditation
is much different david asked god
that his meditation be acceptable
in his sight so that implies to me that
some meditation is
unacceptable amen and the final
meditation will probably cover more
in the next program or in the next uh
time of sharing
but it's silent meditation which you've
just described
to a certain degree staring at the
candle but
also many uh christians special
catholics
following contemplative prayer methods
talk about entering
the silence yes and they always seem to
refer to that scripture be still and
know that i
am god and in the next session
i'll explain okay i'll explain
the depth of that how that has
absolutely
nothing to do with meditation amen
nothing to do with meditation
and yet the whole concept is you awaken
yourself
mystically and put yourself in a
position where you can receive
supernatural mystical experiences by
just
absolute silence but that's not biblical
meditation
either there was a movie that was made
on
ignatius loyola and i think in there
there was a long period of time that the
that the two that were part of this main
story um sat
in silence yeah the voices that they
began to hear
and things and i mean i think about that
in just a real you know
outside of this if you got put in
solitary confinement
for days you can kind of go crazy i mean
you start hearing things
stuff starts talking to you and you know
your mind so
uh yeah that's that that's interesting i
don't think it's wrong to steal the mind
and and when i'm praying and i'm
meditating
on a bible passage i don't just rush
through it and read it
i very slowly and prayerfully and
worshipfully read it and mix it with
worshipfulness toward god
but i'll pause and i'll listen
but if you're not careful you can
create by your own imagination what you
think
could be the voice of god so and and so
you have to be very careful
god doesn't have to have a space of time
to speak to you in fact
usually when god speaks to me it's an
interruption
he just bursts into my life at an
unexpected time
speaks to me especially in dreams i'll
wake up and hear his voice
resonating in my heart and so
it's a little manipulative and there's
that word
uh to try and think that if i pause then
i'm
listening to hear the voice of god like
okay it's your turn god you can talk now
that's manipulating and controlling god
it doesn't work that way but it does
calm the mind and give the holy spirit
an opportunity
to speak revelation to your heart so i
don't want to
make people scared of being
calm in god's prayer but
you don't enter the silence in order to
experience god
god is not this great void of emptiness
uh god is a very personal god that wants
relationship
and communication amen amen
several i think eastern disciplines
where there have been monks or devotees
who have vowed
vows of silence right right is that
related to this
oh yeah if you there's buddhist retreats
where you'll spend a whole week
where you don't say anything you'll eat
in silence you'll
do everything in silence so then 10 days
or
15 days or whatever we also know in
christianity
there were monks who took
vows of silence you know and
if you look at the bible god god never
gives us
this idea that we're just to remain
silent for
huge spans of time it says you know
rejoice in the lord pray without ceasing
it tells us to praise the lord it you
know we're supposed to
uplift our voices and communicate
absolutely
praise god and amen not just remain in
silence
i don't believe god wants people to to
live behind the walls of a monastery
amen when the holy spirit came in the
upper room
jesus foretold the happening and he said
you shall receive power
after the holy spirit has come upon you
and you shall be witnesses
unto me so the whole thrust
was going into all the world and
preaching the gospel to every creature
not retreating behind walls
and living in silence that's not to
diminish the passion that these people
have
who have done that yeah what
self-discipline it takes
to in fact right after i got saved i was
on my way to a monastery having been
raised catholic i thought well i want to
get closer to the lord
i'm going to become a catholic monk
thank god god redirected my path
because this guy picked me up
hitchhiking that held a knife to my neck
and told me he was going to kill me
and i started preaching the gospel to
him and he ended up getting saved
but i said god i take this as a sign and
i'm not supposed to be a monk
amen anyway you want to share
when jesus really gets a hold of your
heart it's like you can't keep quiet you
know
and that's the natural reaction is like
okay i need to tell my family i need to
go tell my neighbors you know i need to
just
talk about this amazing thing that's
happened to me and you see that example
in the bible when
when god really transforms people's
lives there's something that
that just came to my mind too like when
you talk about the silence especially
since that's being brought into the
church which we're not going to get into
that on this program but
on a future one
the whole idea of silence you know if
i'm if i'm struggling with a problem
in my family you know and i come to work
or i come here to see you guys and i say
i think what's wrong eric i mean you're
counting it's just showing something's
wrong and i go well this is what's
happening i'm getting advice
if i'm alone and i'm not
allowing there to be a voice that i can
physically hear
i'm turning inward i'm looking inward
god never tells us to look inward and
stay focused there
to look upward so when i look up and i
stay focused on christ
here's the word of god so by opening my
mind
here if i shut everything down
and i say i'm not going to speak it it
turns me
inward with an expectation that i'm
going to hear something from inside and
it doesn't mean that god doesn't speak
to us because he does
i'll be reading my my bible and
sometimes god will be like
eric i'm talking to you right there
that's that's you you need to
do this or fix this or stop doing this
but if that focus is inward and i'm like
i wonder if that was god speaking
i wonder if that was just my conscience
i wonder if it's just my imagination
i'm opening the door up for the devil to
start whispering which he does
good enough without us being silent that
opens a door
up to for strong potential danger
well also and this kind of puts the cap
on it
when jesus was baptized in the river
jordan
the holy spirit came upon him appearing
in the form of a dove and the father
said this is my beloved son in whom i am
well pleased
amen and he goes to the synagogue of
nazareth
and he did not say the spirit of the
lord god is upon me for he has anointed
me
to become a monk and to live
in the caves of the southern judean
demon
it was all about mingling with people
and bringing change amen because four of
the five things mentioned in isaiah
the spirit of the lord god is upon me he
quoted from isaiah 61.
yes for he has anointed me to preach
good tidings to the meek
to bind up the brokenhearted to proclaim
liberty to the captives
and the opening of the prison to them
that are bound and to proclaim the
acceptable year of the lord
so four of the five things involve
talking
amen but to balance it out now
after he was uh encountered
after he had this encounter with the
father there at his baptism
he went into the wilderness for 40 days
of seeking god and and so seeking god is
not wrong but he came out with his main
mission
and his main purpose and that was to
bring change in people's lives
like for me to to to isolate myself so
that i can hear god's voice there's an
easy way to do that tell yourself
this week i'm not turning the television
on i'm not turning the radio on
i'm not going to do email i'm not going
to do texting
then you've got time to spend that goal
i can't reach you sometime
you bring a good point we often will
just quickly
go to well i'm going to silence anything
and then
use that time with god but we're not
silencing these other voices
throughout our lives and you know people
will have no problem
leaving the tv on all day in the
background yeah but it's like when you
spend that time with god
you know well we have spent a lot of
time
talking about what's wrong on the next
session
or in the next session we're going to
talk about what's right
and all the biblical exhortations
to proper meditation and i believe
that's going to be really helpful
really informative too i do too awesome
all right well that's been a broad
survey
of meditation in all kinds of other
realms and as you guys heard in a future
program
we're going to talk about proper
biblical
meditation and what that looks like so
we hope you've enjoyed this episode
and we hope you join us for the next one
this has been led live and we will see
you next time
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the duelist who they say can speak
with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation at a local
school and concern from parents the
death note is derived from a japanese
animated show the girl told authorities
she got the idea from a cartoon network
show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over 5 million views on
youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
[Music]
this
you